kohle ausstieg aber wie die braunkohle
länder streiten um geld und den zeitplan
die kanzlerin soll schlichten
paukenschlag in moskau putin baut den
machtapparat um regierungschef mit vegf
tritt zurück
ein schlechter tag für spitzel und
spione vor 30 jahren stürmen ddr-bürger
die stasi-zentrale und retten jede menge
akten vor dem reißwolf
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute mittwoch dem 15 januar den sport
hat weder norbert lehmann einen schönen
gruß von mir
es könnte ein langer abend werden im
kanzleramt heute da sitzen nämlich
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten der kohle länder
zusammen um den fahrplan für den
ausstieg aus der braunkohle festzulegen
bis 2038 soll mit dieser art der
stromgewinnung in deutschland ja schluss
sein dem klima zuliebe
doch sind im braunkohlebergbau rund
20.000 menschen beschäftigt was wird aus
ihnen die tagebaue liegen im rheinischen
mitteldeutschen und lausitzer revier
pro jahr werden dort etwa 166 millionen
tonnen braunkohle abgebaut christoph
distel wie schluss machen mit der kohle
möglichst schnell aber fair für alle
der plan steht eigentlich vor einem jahr
vorgestellt von der zuständigen
kommission viel passiert ist seitdem
nicht und so befürchten sie etwa in der
lausitz der mühsam erzielte kompromiss
könnte zum nachteil des ostens
aufgeweicht werden folglich ist die
stimmung in der region inzwischen so
dass auch mir gesagt wird das wird wohl
wieder nicht klappen
und da wäre zum beispiel der streit um
datteln 4 in nordrhein-westfalen
steinkohlekraftwerk brandneu relativ
sauber schnell ans netz damit empfiehlt
ministerpräsident laschet für den
klimaschutz wenn das unternehmen
nachweist wir nehmen das ans netz aber
schalten andere schneller ab als geplant
und die co2 bilanz danach besser wird
finde ich ist das in ordnung für datteln
andere schneller abschalten sagt sich so
leicht würde aber konkret wohl das
kraftwerk schkopau treffen in
sachsen-anhalt 2000 arbeitsplätze
könnten wegfallen gar nicht fair und
auch nicht so ausgemacht kontakt
ministerpräsident haseloff ich kann
nicht sein dass wir in ostdeutschland
nach der wiedervereinigung fast die
gesamte co2 ersparnis für deutschland
gebracht haben
um die klimaziele in brüssel einzuhalten
und jetzt nochmal bluten sollen west
gegen ost miese stimmung beim
kohleausstieg und das ist nur einer von
streitpunkten die wichtigsten wie
rechtzeitig neue arbeitsplätze für die
betroffenen schaffen wie sicherstellen
dass die zugesagten 40 milliarden für
den strukturwandel wirklich ankommen wie
die kraftwerksbetreiber fürs abschalten
entschädigen
ziemlich viel stoff für einen abend im
kanzleramt
ja und da reden die beteiligten seit
wenigen minuten theo koll vor dem
kanzleramt da scheint sich ein neuer
konflikt zwischen ost und west
anzubahnen oder theo eindeutig ja der
ist im prinzip ja auch schon da der
kraftwerks tausch moderne nordrhein
westfalen gegen alte in sachsen-anhalt
der dinge ja eindeutig zu lasten einer
strukturschwachen region im osten wir
hören jetzt aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium das eines der
möglichen angebote an sachsen anhalt
sein könnte das schon bis ende 2022 mehr
steinkohle kraftwerke als vorgesehen vom
netz gehen könnten und das hieße dann
eine längere laufzeit für das
braunkohlekraftwerks körper in sachsen
anhalt gerade in den betroffenen
östlichen bundesländern sind die
ministerpräsidenten erheblich unter
druck der afg und das macht den konflikt
auch zu mehr als einem reinen
wirtschaftlichen was die vier kohle
länder aber eins ist die forderung dass
die von der bundesregierung zugesagten
40 milliarden euro für den umbau auch
langfristig im haushalt festgeschrieben
werden also ein abend heute bei dem es
im doppelten sinn um kohle geht morgen
wird es mir mehr vielen dank theo koll
überraschung in russland die regierung
von ministerpräsident mit bdf hat ihren
rücktritt angekündigt zuvor hatte
präsident putin in seiner rede zur lage
der nation eine verfassungsreform
vorgeschlagen wonach der
ministerpräsident in zukunft vom
parlament gewählt werden soll
über putins pläne und was dahintersteckt
christiansen
16 uhr 32 in moskau das russische
staatsfernsehen mit einer eilmeldung
russlands ministerpräsident mit wwf und
die regierung treten zurück
kurz danach putin und medwedew der
präsident und sein engster vertrauter
und da schon ex-ministerpräsident
erklären den rücktritt mit anstehenden
änderungen im politischen system
russlands als regierung der russischen
föderation müssen wir dem präsidenten
unseres landes die möglichkeit geben
alle erforderlichen maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
in diesem moment halte ich es für
richtig dass die amtierende regierung
gemäss artikel 117 der verfassung zurück
dritte das war's damit hatte niemand
gerechnet selbst betroffene minister
sollen nichts davon gewusst haben
am mittag hatte präsident putin noch
seinen jährlichen auftritt mit seiner
rede zur lage der nation
ungewöhnlich frühen ja er redete vor
allem über soziale themen aber auch über
eine verfassungsänderung
das parlament soll mehr macht bekommen
indem es den ministerpräsidenten und die
minister bestimmt dass der präsident
wird nicht berechtigt sein die vom
parlament bestätigten kandidaten für die
entsprechenden ämter abzulehnen und als
in russland noch alle rätseln was das
für putins machterhalt bedeuten soll
tritt plötzlich die regierung zurück es
geht alles ganz schnell heute in moskau
mit webers nachfolger als
ministerpräsident wurde auch schon
benannt michael niehues den bislang
leiter der russischen steuerbehörde der
frage russland korrespondentin vilbel
wie ist diese überraschende rochade von
präsident putin zu deuten
vieles spricht dafür dass wir hier heute
beobachten können wie präsident putin
seinen machterhalt über das jahr 20 24
hinaus organisiert dann endet seine
jetzige amtszeit und nach der derzeit
gültigen verfassung dürfte er dann nicht
mehr als präsident in russland antreten
im land wird schon lange darüber
spekuliert welchen posten er dann
vielleicht für sich in anspruch nehmen
könnte
oder wie er eben versuchen würde an der
macht zu bleiben
viele haben sich heute von der rede zur
lage der nation ein hinweis genau darauf
erhofft und dann ganz genau hingehört
als präsident putin anfing über mögliche
änderungen in der verfassung zu sprechen
die würden für russland eine deutliche
verschiebung der macht bedeuten und zwar
weg vom amt des präsidenten
interessanterweise hin zu anderen
verfassungsorganen so sollen ja zb das
parlament gestärkt werden und dann
künftig über ministerpräsidenten und
minister entscheiden dürfen
der rücktritt der regierung jetzt kommt
aber natürlich zu einem zeitpunkt
anzunehmen ist noch anweisungen putin
ist die posten neu zu besetzen und so
kann er jetzt eine regierung ernennen
die seinen zukunftsplänen wie auch immer
die aussehen mögen dann unterstützend
zur seite steht
vielen dank für ihre analyse für begann
in moskau die deutsche wirtschaft ist
2009 10 im zehnten jahr hintereinander
gewachsen
mit einem plus von 0,6 prozent hat das
wachstum aber an schwung verloren
der export wuchs nur leicht spürbar
waren die unsicherheiten in der praxis
und der handelsstreit zwischen den usa
und china ausgelöst haben darunter litt
vor allem die autobranche stark hingegen
waren der konsum und die boomende
bauwirtschaft der klimaschutz wird nun
auch ein fall für das
bundesverfassungsgericht mehrere
beschwerden richten sich gegen die
bundesregierung der vorwurf ihre
maßnahmen und beschlüsse etwa zum
klimapaket seien unzureichend kläger
sind jugendliche von frei ist for future
unterstützt von greenpeace der deutschen
umwelthilfe und germanwatch
sie begründeten in berlin ihre
verfassungsbeschwerde ihr ziel
karlsruhe soll die bundesregierung
zwingen mehr für den klimaschutz zu tun
die rot rot grüne minderheitsregierung
in thüringen steht
linke spd und grüne haben sich auf pro
ihr programm verständigt
die idee parteispitzen am abend in
erfurt mitteilten enthält es gemeinsame
projekte wie ein drittes beitragsfreies
kita-jahr mehr schulsozialarbeiter und
eine mobilitätsgarantie für menschen auf
dem land die dreier koalition regiert
thüringen seit 2014 hatte jedoch bei der
landtagswahl im vergangenen oktober ihre
mehrheit verloren
das büro des spd bundestagsabgeordneten
karamba diaby in halle an der saale ist
angegriffen worden
in der fensterscheibe wurden fünf
einschusslöcher festgestellt der aus dem
senegal stammende politiker wurde in der
vergangenheit immer wieder opfer
rassistischer anfeindungen
wie die polizei mitteilte haben
unbekannte auf mehrere gebäude in der
straße geschossen
polizei und staatsschutz ermitteln
wiederholt hatte es angriffe und
gewaltandrohungen gegen politiker
gegeben
in die usa zum nächsten schritt im
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump die demokraten im
repräsentantenhaus wollen noch heute die
anklageschrift dem senat übergeben
damit beginnt dort formell das verfahren
gegen trump der vorwurf amtsmissbrauch
und behinderung der ermittlungen im
repräsentantenhaus
was für eine amtsenthebung müsste sich
im senat eine zweidrittel-mehrheit
aussprechen das gilt als sehr
unwahrscheinlich
im zoll konflikt usa china gibt es eine
erste einigung ein teilabkommen im
weißen haus wurde es soeben feierlich
verkündet die zeit gegenseitiger
strafzölle scheint zu ende zu gehen
es ist ein teurer konflikt für beide
seiten im vergangenen jahr brach der
export chinesische güter in die usa
massiv ein
nach vorläufigen zahlen um rund 100
milliarden us dollar das export minus
der usa in china lag bei rund 25
milliarden
jetzt also ein erster schritt um den
handelskrieg zu beenden aus washington
jenes drums 86 seiten sind übrig
geblieben von einem papier das mal 150
seiten dick war es ist nicht das
umfassende abkommen dass präsident trump
immer forderte doch er will es feierlich
vor 200 gästen unterzeichnen
jump ist wegen des
amtsenthebungsverfahrens unter druck er
will einen erfolg und sei es einen
kleinen es ist ein unglaublicher deal
für die usa für beide seiten er wird in
der welt für stabileren frieden sorgen
teil eins eines handels pakets die
chinesen versprechen deutlich mehr
energie industriegüter und vor allem
agrarprodukte aus den usa zu kaufen
insgesamt im wert von 200 milliarden
dollar auch sagen sie zu geistiges
eigentum zu respektieren im gegenzug
verzichten die usa auf neue zölle die
bestehenden strafzölle bleiben jedoch
größtenteils in kraft schönes fiction
wir werden nie teil zwei des pakets bald
beginnen solange werden die zölle
bestehen bleiben das schockiert einige
aber ich werde sie erst erlassen sofern
wir phase 2 erreichen eine waffenpause
im handelskrieg zwischen den präsidenten
ski und trump vertagt sind streitpunkte
wie staatliche subventionen für
chinesische unternehmen
es ist eine monumentale niederlage für
präsident
da er es nicht geschafft hat die
struktur der chinesischen wirtschaft zu
verändern
die subvention entspricht dieser deal
nicht an trumps finanzminister hat
bereits neue zölle angedroht sofern die
chinesen das abkommen nicht umsetzen der
handelskrieg er ist längst nicht vorbei
die menschenrechtsorganisation human
rights watch wirft china einen
beispiellosen angriff auf die
menschenrechte vor in dem land herrsche
die brutalste unterdrückung seit
jahrzehnten vor allem gegenüber
muslimischen minderheiten der chef von
human rights watch kenneth rogoff
demokratischen staaten dazu auf
entschieden dagegen vorzugehen zb durch
das einfrieren chinesische
auslandsvermögen die regierung in peking
wies die vorwürfe zurück
die ddr staatssicherheit war das
instrument der regierung um millionen
deutsche auszuspionieren und zu
drangsalieren
heute vor 30 jahren besetzten
demonstranten die stasi-zentrale um die
vernichtung von akten zu verhindern
wer hat wen wie bespitzelt das interesse
an solchen fragen ist ungebrochen
7,3 millionen anträge auf einsicht in
die stasiakten wurden gestellt und
aktenmaterial gibt es reichlich
insgesamt 111 kilometer lang aus berlin
roman lesbar und henriette de maizière
fünfzehnter januar 1990 früher abend
tausende demonstranten strömen zur
stasizentrale die angst vor
aktenvernichtung treibt viele um
mittendrin damals christian halbrock
sein erster blick hinter die
unüberwindbaren tore
man kannte dieses bild von der
staatssicherheit und dann war das alles
auf einmal so mittelmäßig und
nichts und eine menschenverachtende
behörde im biedermeier charme
nach der erstürmung endet die arbeit im
verborgenen die stasi wird schließlich
aufgelöst
30 jahre danach ist der bundespräsident
gekommen um den einsatz der beteiligten
zu würdigen wie viel mut gehörte zu
diesem friedlichen sturm auf die
bastionen der repression wie viel mut
gehörte dazu in dieser zeit des chaos in
der die macht der staatssicherheit noch
bewaffnet war aus dem
unterdrückungsapparat wird letztlich die
stasi unterlagenbehörde bis heute setzen
mitarbeiter geschredderte dokumente
mühevoll zusammen rund 57.000
bundesbürger beantragten vergangenes
jahr die akteneinsicht
wir sind auch zum trog bild für viele
viele länder geworden die impro
situationen erlebt haben die auch
unterlagen der vorherrschenden nutzen um
aufzuklären
die künftig ändert sich allerdings die
zuständigkeit für die akten kommendes
jahr sollen die bestände ins
bundesarchiv überführt werden und nun zu
dir norbert kuntze
handball-europameisterschaft ja
untersteht deutschland zum beginn der
hauptrunde gewaltig unter druck morgen
das erste gruppenspiel gegen
weissrussland ein sieg ist pflicht für
das team von trainer christian prokop
sonst dürfte es mit dem halbfinaleinzug
sehr sehr schwierig werden ein anderes
ambiente für deutschlands handball
spieler jetzt also wien stadt trondheim
nach einer schwierigen vorrunde die
analysiert und abgearbeitet sein soll
neustadt möchte ich gar nicht ausrufen
sondern wir haben sehr viele
erkenntnisse aus der vorrunde genommen
und jetzt geht es darum perfekt in die
richtige richtung zu gehen
zwei die das bislang am ehesten gemacht
haben sind julius kühn und timo kasten
kühn war beim zittersieg gegen lettland
den hof laune linkshänder casting
überzeugt durch seine unbekümmertheit
eigenschaften die für die hauptrunde
gefragt sind und zwar schon morgen gegen
weißrussland das nach siegen gegen
serbien und montenegro in bessere
stimmung ist als die deutsche mannschaft
beim biathlon weltcup in ruhpolding
wurde vanessa hinz als achte beste
deutsche beim 7,5 kilometer sprint
während snowboarderin ramona hofmeister
von sieg zu sieg reist heute gewann sie
beim weltcup in bad gastein auch den
teamwettbewerb im parallelslalom
zusammen mit stefan baumeister
angelique kerber hat beim wta-turnier in
adelaide in achtelfinale verletzt
aufgeben müssen und vor beginn der
australian open in melbourne gab es
heute tennis begegnungen der besonderen
art melbourne eine der lebenswertesten
städte der welt leidet unter den
höchsten feinstaubwerte das training für
die australian open ausgesetzt
man hat es wirklich auch gebrochenen der
luft und
ja auch atmen viel schwerer als sonst
dann ist er da der regen auf den alle
gehofft haben
er soll die luft reinigen für das
wochenende ist noch mehr angekündigt das
erste major-turnier des jahres dürfte
wohl am montag planmäßig starten
benefizveranstaltung für die opfer der
brände alle stars geben sich die ehre
unterm hallendach roger federer und ich
werden 250.000 australische dollar
spenden für die opfer der brände
[Applaus]
mittwoch und zeit für die lottozahlen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 28 24 31 43 46
und die superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
das januar wetter sieht eher nach märz
aus es wird sonnig und mild wo es ein
bisschen winterlich ist das sagt uns
gleich gunther tiersch das war es von
uns danke für ihr interesse
christian sievers und das heute journal
um 21.45 und wir sind morgen abend
wieder zur stelle punkt 19 uhr
machen sie es gut
[Musik]
einige zuschauer heute nacht wird im
norden mal kurz nas morgen wird es dann
aber wieder überwiegend sonnig auch in
norddeutschland und es bleibt mild zehn
grad höchsttemperatur so etwa in
mitteleuropa und auch im osten vermisst
man dem frost osteuropa fünf bis zehn
grad höchsttemperatur ganz ungewöhnlich
für mitte januar bei uns wird wegen ein
bisschen frost jährlichen bayern wieder
bis minus 3 grad sonst meist frostfrei
zwei bis sieben grad morgen früh
dazu ist es bewölkt von westen her aber
dieser regen der da fällt er wird auf
dem weg nach osten immer schwächer und
es ist auch nicht mehr so windig ja
morgen wird es dann recht freundlich der
wind dreht ja auf süd ist nur noch sehr
schwach sonne habe im norden sonne im
süden zwischendrin allerdings am main
zum tröstlichen bayern ist es stärker
bewölkt zum nachmittag kommt die sonne
raus und es ist nicht mehr ganz so warm
aber immer noch sehr mild acht bis elf
grad sind es meist 14 gerade stuttgart
und freiburg im östlichen bayern bleibt
ein bisschen frischer und die aussichten
nach einem freundlichen freitag wird es
von westen her bewölkt mit regenschauern
das wochenende wird ein bisschen kühler
wechselhafter mit schnee in den bergen
und südlich der donau ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut